this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised a very good afternoon to you all
welcome to the sunset safari of today my
name is Lauren and on camera
I do have Senzo the lucky jewel so
fingers crossed it's gonna be a lucky
day today because it has been rather dry
in terms of animals here but you must
talk to us you must send in all your
questions and lovely comments using the
hashtag spoiler on Twitter or on the
YouTube chat stream so before I Drive
any further it is of course Mother's Day
in some parts of the world not the UK
but in some parts of the world like here
it's Mother's Day so happy Mother's Day
to all the mothers godmothers
grandmothers even aunts and sisters or
the fantastic females that look after
children now saying so and I have been
practicing are you ready since so I'm
gonna sing a little song using our
musical carats sans was gonna start he's
got a much better voice than me and I'm
just gonna go with it okay since take it
away you Mother's Day to you all we
should care
[Music]
happy Mother's Day to you
oh yeah I'm so glad we got to do that
with their musical carriers but it's
between practice and really really
really hard so I hope you like that
carrots are a wonderful thing to sing
tune I was eating his by the way so it
wasn't microphone and now that is a
snack so in all seriousness we are on
the search for lots of animals past few
drives have been quiet and that's nature
that happens of course so I keep saying
I've got my spotted hyenas this morning
but it really is time to find a leopard
it is so we are on a mission and that is
exactly what I am going to do and of
course we will stop for all the
wonderful things along the way and the
main topic of today will be of course
shall be have on Mother's and animals ID
here being good mothers or bad mothers
then of course please do send them in so
as we drive on and I am gonna eat my
carrot now please let's go across to
Jamie and say good afternoon
hello good afternoon and welcome to the
sunset Safari my name is James Henry and
I have a mother too as do all of us
David Easter is on camera there is so
happy and enthusiastic and our plan
today of course is to head down towards
the western edge of Juma and find
anything
as I'm sure Loren has explained we have
our TV show coming up this evening we've
tracked one cat off the reserve so far
and had no sign of any other cat at all
so all rather nerve-racking at the
moment hopefully we'll do a little
better than we have we have in fact been
out all day here is a cat track of a
lion now if this lion is on the reserve
I shall be deeply pleased and you see
the tracks there David look Lion tracks
imagine we found lion
unfortunately you know they're on top of
the vehicle tracks so that's quite fun
actually
alright let's see where they go
it's like a male line - okay we'll
follow up obviously we are on the
northern boundary so most likely it's
gone away but if not we'll be very lucky
and find it let us now go across to
Jamie Patterson who will all say say
hello and tell you of her trials oh
please please let there be a lion on
Zuma that would be a huge relief a very
good afternoon to you all my name is
Jamie and this afternoon
creig is on a camera with me a happy
Mother's Day to all of the mothers out
there including my own who I think has
had a rather rough day so I'm sending
her lots of love but yes happy birthday
happy Mother's Day to all of the mothers
out there and of course for those of you
who've lost your mothers we thinking of
you too
and I'm sure you're thinking of them
today unless you're in the UK in which
case sorry mother's days been has
happened or is it still going to happen
I don't know I lose track when the
calendars get all different like that so
we're going to have a drive I think
spent given that we can't find anything
apparently it has happened given that we
can't find anything we are oh dear
that's not a good hold on one moment
sorry
sorry-sorry give me one second
given that we've found absolutely
nothing on Juma and we've worked pretty
hard to try and find the cat's today
we're probably going to have a drive
spent reminiscing about our favorite
mother related sightings and there are
plenty of them we've got lots to draw on
so I think over the course of the drive
we're definitely just sorry I'm trying
to listen and speak at the same time
because I've got to get off this one of
us has got to get off this property
there's two vehicles out from Juma so
I'm gonna hit the boundary very shortly
hmm okay torch what it is guys that's
the plan for me then
[Music]
afternoon Rick's you know that elephant
that you found tracks for yesterday at
waffles up damn it's been seen around
the fire break waffles look east and Lee
doesn't agree good
copy copy or Berber look now halogen or
sorry yesterday we were talking about
tracking ting gana on his way towards
muffles huh before zag damn and tax
Rick's actually called and said look
there's tracks of an elephant with quite
a bad limp around this area so we're
just gonna go have a look apparently it
was there Paulie has been very kindly
helping us in the search for animals and
he found it there earlier so we're gonna
go have a look at that I don't feel like
a particularly sad sighting though not
today Chris you say happy Mother's Day
to me for the motherhood of the puppy
yes thank you very much she's so cute I
get lots of videos all day and feel very
sad that I am missing out on these
little moments but it's okay I feel as
though she has a strong father figure in
her life
although puppy that sighs anything is
strong she's very sweet even if I did
get removed from the naming process
which I feel quite insulted by okay well
well done Lauren while I make my way
onto the boundary Lauren's managed to
find you at least an animal or two let's
go and find out which ones they are is
marked so it's slightly different which
is why I didn't wish her but happy
Mother's Day mom so we did just have
some Impala you can see they're off in
the distance and there's actually quite
a mixed group here
these ones are females and there's
youngsters in there and we do have some
males across to the other side
hmmm what's happening there ladies are
you getting chased off by the meals here
sorry there's a lot happening behind I'm
actually just gonna turn the car beer
with me the meals are cold I'm not gonna
turn the carts that is stalled the males
are chasing females let's just take a
look at what is going mm with the
impalas is that ok sense okay huh so
what I was gonna say later before it all
went a bit crazy with the impalas the
males are closely following these
females here as I was gonna mention all
my mother's day of course and it's
interesting when you compare the
antelope species got a beautiful meal
here I think you're the one causing all
the trouble aren't you I feel like you
are looking a bit frustrated there shall
we say when you compare antelope mothers
and birthing period and lactation period
with those of their predators it does
vary quite dramatically so obviously
with your cats they have a very very
short pregnancy period and the young are
born very very needle completely out
Rishel and they depends heavily on their
mothers but of course with the antelope
species which is the pre of most of
these cats give or take it's a much
longer gestation period or and 6.5
months for impalas so they're obviously
inside of the mother much longer and
when they're born they're much more
fully developed so they can kind of hit
the ground running if you like and this
is exactly because they are the main pre
species for the big cats so when they
are born they've literally just got to
get on with that they've got to hit the
ground running they can walk very very
soon after birth and then not long after
that they will be running and trying to
keep up with their mothers and that's
obviously Nature's Way of survival of
the fittest so the cats are born very
very weak very underdeveloped
find known as out Rochelle I'm just
gonna catch up with the attempt at
impalas but the impalas are the complete
opposite and I find that utterly
fascinating so they're all huddled
together here in a mixed group we can
see lots of young some mothers and there
is some meals rain is wondering if the
impalas can run incredibly fast by
needing yes of course they can because
running is their main escape from the
predators and of course Impala of such a
wide range of predators they do have a
lot to fear out here in the bush and
they can run really really fast and they
can also movie so believe it or not when
you see an Impala leap is quite it's
quite something to see and they're even
said to sort of that go very very high
very very long many many body lengths
and Impala can leap the males are really
causing quite a stir here and I don't
believe the females are too happy with
it they're a little bit uncomfortable
that there's a male chasing come around
here get an amazing sun's all around us
right now so the meals are behind us we
can't actually show you we're gonna
stick he knows for a little bit longer
so yes they can run very very fast and
that is how they escape but it's really
fascinating when you watch an Impala
face a predator let's say for example a
leopard and they really stand their
ground they sort of operate on as long
as I can see you and not scared of you
it will actually face a standoff for the
predator and for example them back to
the leopards they can actually back down
as soon as they know they've been seen
it's game over so they won't actually
run away from a predator if they can see
it they will stand their ground they
will face it they will look at the
predator and of course they will alarm
call so for being sort of scared nervous
creatures out here we have a lot to fear
they are incredibly good at standing
their ground when there's actually
something to face and this is a large
hair look at the mall just walking on by
I just think they're absolutely stunning
stunning animals with the huge eyes and
ears which shows they really rely on
these senses especially when Saints and
what is going on around them they will
listen and they will look JD constantly
on the search for predators so while we
enjoy this moment with the impalas in
the North Sea males we are going to send
you back across to James we still
tracking some lions
no the Lions I'm afraid of gone north of
the reserve what we're looking at here
is from white crystal helmet right to a
very very upset and I think it's because
there's a territorial dispute here there
seemed to be two flocks sticks to each
other that is in there as well that's in
fact that's a predominant noise you can
hear it even on Mother's Day like this
it's very slightly and that was
just peer into the thick foliage
underneath there and see if we can see
any spots there you upset those birds
perhaps it was conflict between the
Betances and the white christed helmet
racks
you see leopard in there David note here
okay
probably isn't one in
sometimes these birds accurate most of
the time they are not I must confess I
agree with Emma who says everything is
starting to look like leopards now yes
it is
nope
let us continue good on we go
so we went to check at the Dan that's
just north of the boundary
Sydney's dam and they apparently the
tracks went up that way and the whole
pride was hurt crossing into the Munya
Yeti which is the government reserved to
the north of us around about seven
o'clock this morning I think so they
probably won't be back
say we'll continue and see what else we
can find
I'll tell you that during the day what
what was that
let me catch that sorry and Emma Chris
says what about watch helmet strikes ah
what is the size of a territory of the
helmet strike I must confess to you I
couldn't give you any idea but I says
probably roughly the same size as that
of the Greenwood Phu Phu which we can
see over there I'll see if anyone's
worked it out few chrous there is a
Christian Bobbitt
there was a Greenwood Hoopoe there too I
think it did fly off David you see if
anybody has ever researched the size of
the white crystal helmet racks territory
it dated somehow but it's possible
trustingly quite often the prey of
battle ear African Harrier Hawkin Gabbar
goshawk resident but not sad entry
groups leave territories post breeding
in response to diminishing resources
okay so there are only territorial
during the breeding season that's
interesting which should be well
finished by now
you know I can't see any thighs here oh
here we go
breeding density linked to habitat
patchiness circle one group per 20
hectares in me ombre woodland where get
me on by woodland here that's found the
northern Zimbabwe up into into Zambia
but this is not observed elsewhere
groups formed by cohort or female
siblings that leave natal group and join
cohort of male siblings dispersed from
another group basically they're wild
dogs yes
here we go territory on beating seasons
Beautif ending 1 to 12 hectares 5
hectares on average as their sample size
of 63 so they go 5 hectares Chris 5
hectares being roughly times 2.4 12
acres also did you see my brain working
David
thanks for that Chris I had no idea I'd
never thought to look it up amazed of
course that somebody has done that sort
of research I suppose I shouldn't be
amazed people research all sorts of
weird things and that's actually quite
interesting all right so our next little
trip is going to be up towards the gates
just to make sure that we've covered the
northwestern corner and on that note
funnily enough we're going to go across
to Jamie who is a also searching
I know wouldn't you know it great minds
think alike we're both searching for
four things
well I found scuba Steve but I'm not
going to stay for very long I just want
to stay long enough that we can look at
scuba Steve and I can listen to that
Franklin that's making funny sounds on
the opposite bank just to check that
there is not a leopard hiding there
that's see an Impala that I suspected
actually gone running through being
chased away by another male and I think
that's probably what's caused that
Franklin's discomfort hello Steve scuba
Steve not to be confused with Steve
Faulconbridge
I have Mr Steve already today where the
lipids are he is he is thoroughly
thoroughly unhelpful you know somebody
points it out and I cannot unsee it now
that's Scuba Steve only ever blows water
properly out of his right nostril and
not his left and I absolutely fascinated
by this I wonder whether or not he
sustained an injury of some kind to his
left nostril or perhaps he's just one of
those people with a perpetually blocked
nostril or hippos I don't know who get
heroes who are perpetually find
themselves with the blocked nostril I'm
gonna give him another few seconds and
then you'll see it Emma says she feels
that struggle me too especially because
mine comes from the squirrel excrement
that has run down my walls and therefore
depends on which side I'm lying which
nostril I happen to find more blocked
than the other
you're a bird of prey calling otherwise
absolute silence very comfortable
looking in parlor I know when you get
sick and you are you suddenly realized
how little you appreciated the ability
to breathe clearly through both nostrils
and you vowed never to take that ability
for granted ever again this I feel is a
common unifying human right wait for it
wait for it he's gonna know
come on Steve you must need to take the
breath by now I've been a Turing for
long enough oh did he was I just not
watching I'm so busy looking for a lip
but did he blow out of his right nostril
yeah okay well that's good I think Craig
has pointed out that he well I'm so busy
looking for a lip but I'm not actually
watching what the cameras watching
apparently he did actually sorry Steve
my apologies I thought I was just being
so riveting that you were holding your
breath there but that doesn't appear to
be the case I don't know why I keep
finding myself drawn to bottles of Dom
over the last few days well I know why I
was here two nights ago it's wet in
Ghana was Lauren Kirstie and myself went
out on tracking team and due largely to
the efforts of Rickson and her be
assisting us we discovered that at 10
Ghana had crossed out into little Gowri
one more time for me because I missed
the first one nothing can look quite as
dismissive as a hippopotamus to me about
their eyes
never too late said that he did blow a
little bit out of the left nostril there
again I mean he's clearly moving both
nostrils so it's probably just maybe
actually to be fair what might be is
that the right nostril doesn't seal as
well as the left nostril meaning he
attracts more water in it or he ends up
with more water in it with his nose
under shame here we go right nostril
again with dominant nostrils now you see
all that spray from the right nostril
very observant from whoever actually
observed it and I apologize I don't know
where it came from it was sort of fed to
me by the via very very observant Oh
shame a boy I don't know maybe he's
right-handed I think what I can tell you
is that right now he's his back was
getting too hot now he's doing his best
impression of a rock lying on his side
come on lipid this is the perfect
opportunity for you to come down and
drink and surprise us all
and then at six o'clock you can cross
into brothels hook just out of spite
that's what the Lions kept doing to me
every time I had lines before a TV show
they got up and walked across the
boundary as we were about to start I
have yet to be able to tell the story of
the Inca homers and the way I would like
to all right I suppose I'd better crack
on and see what else I can find Lauren
is doing much the same we're all very
original this afternoon let's go see how
she's doing
I am searchin and even some snacks which
sensor has brought along and I'm not
actually a snacker so breaking my own
good and yes we're searchin were
searching high and low
I really feel today is gonna day where
the animals are going to deliver but
been thinking a lot about parental care
just because it is Mother's Day of
course and parental care just differs so
much across the between the likes of
mammals and dry up to the tiles even
fish there's such a big friends and
friends okay okay there are some tracks
here
hold that thought Lauren yes that's me
talking to myself
mmm-hmm potentially hyenas so of course
the PERT sorry about that I think there
was some breakup that was maybe my for
some road so it's likely removing them
and of course every species will do what
is necessary for their offspring and if
it's necessary to send their offspring
out into the world to fend for
themselves and of course that's what
you'll do that's what they'll do so you
have the likes of a crocodile a reptile
who actually does show us very small
element of maternal care the mothers
will once they'll either in a sort of
borrow how did I not see you I'm too
busy talking shall we see if we can do
and there's warthogs
all over the place at the minute there
is a huge boom in the warthog population
and every time we've cited one today
they have been right next to in Paula's
and right here we have a male Impala and
a very large warthog now one of the most
disturbing sighting actually two of the
most disturbing sightings I had an Amara
involved warthogs and
it was very not easy to witness at all
they are under a lot of pressure just
like all the other antelope species from
the big predators here he goes so yes as
I was saying the likes of crocodiles
they will the mothers will actually
ferociously protect their eggs and set
on top of the nest until of course the
eggs are underground she hears the noise
of the babies once they have started
hatching from the egg and that is when
she will go and get in my herself carry
them in her mouth and take them through
the water and there is give or take on
the species there is actually maternal
care for about up to two weeks which is
quite surprising for a reptile Alex of
fish so let's go with the classic Nemo
fish that is so incorrect which I really
not a big fan of calling them the Nemo
fish they are either clownfish or an
enemy fish but they are the most famous
one from the movie Finding Nemo and
there's a lot of parental care involved
in looking after the eggs there so
obviously when the eggs are laid on a
rock or a sort of substrate under water
the both parents will actually look over
the eggs and Erie them by blowing water
which Sainz oxygen through to the eggs
until they hatch
so it just differs on so many different
levels and any of the likes of hyenas
who of course suckle their young for up
to two years two years that's a really
long time to look after your Cubs and
suckle them so the diversity of parental
care right across the animal kingdom is
just utterly fascinating and completely
diverse in every aspect so I am gonna
continue searching before I go on more
about parental care that's my theme of
the day and see if we can actually find
any of the
I've left buffers hope because I did say
to Rex that I would go and check this
elephant out quickly so I do want to
just go and see if I can find it but
police said quarry bush but
unfortunately there's quite a few quarry
bushes on before swabby east but I think
it's closer to the fire break so I'm
just gonna go have a quick look around
there I'm sort of dreading that though
my heart does my heart feels bruised
today it doesn't feel like it can take a
sad sighting with its normal resilience
hmm but best to go and find out how it's
looking because Rex wants to call people
in if necessary
all right so talking about mothers
obviously this is our opportunity to
reminisce on some of our sightings that
have provided us with the best examples
of mothering for me the obvious one that
stands out is Tandy in the baboons which
was a sighting that I had during a
public rehearsal with VMP on Geary main
when tumba and his sister was still tiny
tiny his sibling was still tiny tiny and
Tandy had caught herself three it was
this time of year ich had caught herself
three male Impala and she'd sort of
strung them up in a tree and she was
lying there with the Cubs
we knew that they'd been seen but we we
hadn't seen them the Cubs
Oh was I talking about
oh there he is mr. Han necessary can you
see it there Craig it's quite deep in
that's the back there uh-oh I'm not
actually hurt I'll direct you in mm-hmm
want me to go forward of it I'm not
actually hurt I'm just whining is this
elephant another one it's a very little
one five years old ish anyway tündi
saved I'm Craig I'm gonna go round to
the fire break maybe I can get a bit of
view from there it's moving actually
towards the fire break tun tun D was
looked completely asleep the next thing
she got up and she shot off in the
direction of the way she had her cubs
and we ate first didn't know why and
then this troop of baboons came running
through and baboons are a serious threat
to leopard cubs if they could have
caught them and they did try
they will kill them and when we slowed
down the footage afterwards you just see
this tiny little cub running and this
baboon reaching through the branches to
try and catch it anyway tiny ran
straight in grabbed one of the younger
baboons to distract the males and then
let it go and then ran really slowly in
front of the baboons to lead them away
it was astounding it was such a good
example of mother's courage this hasn't
worked out the way I intended it
oh dear mmm just go down a little bit
I'll turn around again are there it's
but frightened I know baby it's okay
it's all right
my talking's actually not going to help
it at all if it is injured come little
one come out it's lonesome there hasn't
been an elephant herd around here for a
long time it's obviously become
separated from the rest of its herd
future danger it might be a bit older
than I think it what or but I thought it
was now that I see it
steet limping so just going further into
the bush let me just move Craig I'm just
gonna move a bit in case it wants to
come this way concedes limping it
doesn't look as serious as I expected
but I think that might just because I
can't see properly for it to be on its
own like this it's moving off again and
I want to frighten it I'll stress it out
I just want to give an get a quick view
so I can report back on it the obvious
thing is that I'm saying obvious a lot
tonight in first afternoon not so
obvious thing is is that I can't drive
no it's fine no problem is I'm going to
try for one last view is that there's a
possibility that an injury to an
elephant's leg could be caused by
something human related so it's
important that we just check up on it to
see whether or not that is the case we
there's a very solid policy here in the
sands that nature is allowed to take its
course it's a very big open natural
system but there is a possibility oh no
wonder I stalled out my handbrake up
there it is
here is a possibility that it could have
found itself with a snare injury on a
bump here or another human related
injury it might have stood on a nail for
example that does sometimes happen
construction vehicles leave behind but
some tools there obviously strictly
instructed not to
oh well done James I'm gonna sit here
for a little bit and I'm gonna see if
this little elephant will come out while
we do that let's send you across to
James who's managed to find a herd of
healthy elephants
yes I have and these ones are not
injured they are actual heartbeat
genuine animals that we have found
what's more the one you're looking at is
unquestionably a mother a car flying in
amongst these bushes here sure it's very
nice to sit and look at an animal for a
while I know they're in the bushes but
still defeating away having transferred
to trying to get the greenest stuff
that's in the shade and often growing in
the vicinity of the tree roots because
it often makes some slightly more
nutritious probably bit more bacteria in
the soil there and that helps the
grasses absorb a bit more in the way of
nutrition from these very ancient and
nutrient poor soils that we have over
here I'm meant to slip forward until the
darvid because I believe that we will
get a bit of you
and apparently what a nice sound of the
grass being torn from its roots so the
grass doesn't appreciate that the
elephant's do that alright David yes god
there's also a little cover your
Franklin's here yeah care to have a look
at them
once we're done with the elephant see
them
that's very cool
[Laughter]
or a very peaceful Sunday afternoon
scene
well oh I'm afraid I don't have any
updates on short trunk and her herd I
haven't seen or heard of them for a long
time you know it's basically only us who
keeps tabs on those sorts of animals I
mean while the other reserves around the
place do see them from time to time I
think they're pay far more attention to
their cats because they're territorial
and the course they don't have the same
guests every day which basically we do
have the same guests every day they
don't have quite the same attachment to
characters outside of the cat's so you
know I don't know where they are or
what's happened to them but I'm sure
they're okay and they're around
big one emerging and what back then
Becki Anneli mother will never leave her
calf it's kind of the other way around
and if it's her daughter remember that
the calf will live in the herd all its
days and so she and her mother will
probably live together until the mother
dies or you know if that very unnatural
thing occurs where the daughter dies
before the mother otherwise they will be
together for life and if in the case of
a son eventually the mother and her
adult helpers I suppose in the herd so
all the adult females in the herd will
chase him a son away when he's probably
in the ages of 15 and 18 15 froley but
young but between 15 and 18 he'll slowly
be chased away from the herd
because he'll start to become an
irritation very very similar to a 15 to
18 year old boy and so she doesn't leave
him so much or say look buddy it's time
that you packed your bags and went to
find your own way in the world
- one this very angular about the gut
just almost like she's I don't know
there's much white fur to come forward
of it I think it's a she might be a
young bull very difficult to tell at
this age I would have put that out at
about 6 or 7 years old maybe even
younger you know you can just see very
kind of sticky arty ribs just below the
spine I'm not sure why that should be
the case maybe were just the way that
she happens to be built or he happens to
be built I don't know whether that's
male or female I can't tell
now eating little forbs so ignoring the
grass and picking little hopes Cal six
Franklin's are not very closely related
to quails I mean they have a similar
kind of way of life I suppose
but they're not very closely related I
don't think they're in the same family I
think they're in a distinct family and
so I mean they're about as closely
related to quails as we are to Lyons
which doesn't probably help you a great
deal but tells you that they're not very
closely related
I'll just see quickly I may be talking
rubbish I don't think I am but let me
just confirm that I'm not talking
garbage to you just a nice talk garbage
for Sunday afternoon here's the little
tasks are very cute Gabriel I agree with
you 162 in my book
so the Franklin's know if they often the
same family I told you a lie
I'm very sorry I'll give myself a smack
so they're from the same family and that
family is the MMSE any day fast the NRA
which I'm presuming includes pheasants
Sen a day those are all the quails and
they all belong to the genus quartering
caught hot tunics for tunics car tunics
conics photonics unlimited and oh no you
don't need to show all this and then
there are the Franklin's and then the
spur fall so they are in the same family
very nice thank you very much so they're
about as closely related to each other
as we are two monkeys really the Boone's
shrimpanzees probably yeah okay
US and chimpanzees serve in a sort of
relationship shaking off the dirt
all right let's go back to the budding
veterinarian Jamie Patterson and see if
she has managed to diagnose a problem
with her elephant I wish I wish I really
really hasn't made our lives any easier
I can't stay with him the whole Drive
unfortunately I don't know you know the
only alternative is to actually drive
off-road and try and get a little bit
closer to it but what I don't want to do
is frighten an injured animal and causes
even more injury and pain and stress it
already showed a little bit of a few
signs of discomfort at the sound of our
vehicle it's settled now it's feeding
least it's eating and Craig and I were
just discussing you know whether what it
takes for an elephant herd to leave one
of its own the fact that its most likely
a young male chances are and if you know
if it has been injured it in a natural
way it could have been from another male
elephant it's moving it's barely moving
as in walking so I haven't had a chance
now it's stressed I can see it's
secreting from its temporal gland there
joy you want to know will and how if the
authorities will help but sorry that was
terribly phrased but you phrase your
question much better than I did it
depends if it's a natural injury yes if
it's not no sorry if it's a natural
inner injury no if it is a an injury
that's caused by some sort of human
influence then yes they will a very
difficult thing to determine it's almost
impossible to be able to sneak up on
this elephant in the area that it's in
on foot to try and see it and to see
what the injury is it's still small but
it is a danger to people on foot what
will probably end up doing is keeping an
eye on it over the course of a few days
but Rex did ask me to come and have a
look he said he wants to report it and
from there here we are I'm a boy from
there it will be in the hands of the
those who run the reserve please don't
send them messages to tell them about it
I promise you we will handle it from our
end their decisions are hard enough to
make as it is come on
Lily who is eight years old wants to
know whether or not it could join
another herd shaman's listening to the
impala now I mean I can see it doesn't
want to walk sorry Lily hold on one
second I'm just trying to see Lily if
it's a young male and if it recovers
remember animals are very very resilient
then chances are because of the age that
it's at it actually probably will spend
the rest of its life either with a group
of or they'll meet up with some young
males or an older male spend a bit of
time with them and do the normal male
thing which is to be separate from the
main herd but to occasionally come and
join up with a herd every now and again
if it's a female it there's a good
chance it could still find its herd
remember elephants can communicate over
large distances they are capable of
creating sounds that are very very low
frequency that travel very far so it is
entirely possible that it could but we
obviously don't know for now whether
it's a male or a female looks to me to
meet it looks to me to be around about
the age of sexual maturity so but I
think it's the back I think the front is
is fine I think it's something to do
with the back limbs
it could have fallen I mean it could be
something as simple as that could have
while running found itself in a hole
elephants are actually very good at not
doing that alright guys I'm gonna give
it a little bit longer and then I'm
going to move on I do have to start
really looking for animals so oh okay
I'm gonna try and keep up with it while
we try and do that let's send you a
crosser to Lauren for an update on her
side I do wonder what happened to that
elephant we heard about it earlier and
my only wonder I haven't got that injury
what a shame so we're still driving we
found some tracks we doing into this
block here so we're gonna do a look they
were leopard tracks and we are gonna see
if we can just see anything I don't know
why luck is not on my sight these days
identifies me t I just maxed out from
all the luck in the Mara but I was
thinking I would love to hear from you
all as to which animal not individuals
not characters but which species that
you think I would hear and Anna mara as
well of course are the best mothers I've
been thinking about it and thinking
about it I'm not even sure what I would
see my answer is I'm gonna keep thinking
about it I have a selection of different
animals that I personally feel make
absolutely fantastic mothers out here so
I want to hear from you all using the
hashtag Safari live which species do you
think between here and Amara are the
best mothers so I'll tell you some of my
theories of course possibly right at the
top elephant now if you think about the
investment that a female elephant puts
in to motherhood with a very very long
gestation period of almost about 22
months almost
years very long time it's a very large
investment as well for an animal and
then of course staying with the baby for
almost life
the females stay with the haired and
when a female elephant is young
obviously there's a lot of training a
lot of learning a lot of learning about
the environment and learning how to be a
good mother and this obviously comes
from the older females and the haird so
elephant is up there I don't know if I'm
biased or nor potentially I am very
biased but I do feel that the spotted
hyenas are incredibly caring mothers who
really invest a lot of time and effort
into their young as well to meet them
going to strong females or males but
especially the females ELISA agrees with
elephants okay Lisa yeah I'm talking it
through as I'm thinking in case you
can't help many animals out here meet
good mothers but I'm trying to think
which ones really really invest most of
their lifetime into reproduction so I
think mm-hmm yeah okay I finalized my
own thoughts I think for me I would go
with elephants and hyenas but then there
was a very disturbing incident in the
Mara which I witnessed which many of you
me remember where we had a mother
giraffe no giraffes are not extremely
famous for their maternal care however
what I witnessed was absolutely
heartbreaking and for those who weren't
sure there was a mother giraffe who had
just recently given birth to a live calf
and unfortunately the calf died and the
mother stayed by its side for up to four
days and I'm sure it would have stayed
longer but of course
hyenas came in and disrupted the
situation and it was absolutely
heartbreaking to see there was a lot of
maternal care there as well so I've
actually sent myself a very difficult
question but I think I'm gonna stay with
the best mothers out here elephants and
hyenas so share your thoughts and let me
let me hear what you
all think there's obviously probably
many options that I've not even thought
of and we can also see what James and
Jamie think as well but not individuals
not specific individuals I'm just
talking about watch mother which species
make fantastic mothers and I do look
forward to hearing what you all think
you know keep seeing tracks and their
hyena tracks they throw you off every
single time you think it's a cat anymore
you know and hyenas are notorious for
walking everywhere at nighttime so their
tracks are literally everywhere I do
have a funny feeling there's a leopard
somewhere around here we've just got to
find it not an easy task
believe me joy in Hong Kong has seen
giraffe mothers are pretty good yep joy
I'm with you and that one I learned a
lot that day sometimes you know we say
this all the time I'm sure I'm just
sounding like a broken record but it
isn't until you're actually out here and
you spend time with the animals you
witness behaviors and things that you
just don't read online or in text books
and those four days that I spent with
that mother giraffe were very hard I get
very sad I'm an emotional human being we
aren't all but I am and I found it very
very sad to watch that and just see what
she was going through so yes joy I
really do agree with you giraffe mothers
are we more the maternal than people
actually realize and I think the mother
calf bones can actually last well to
heal or just be just before two year
mark so maybe her heart's gonna listen
self oh I'd like to begin this fruit
beams it's exactly what he thinks
there's a little beat here and I think
probably quite a good mother
I think birds are generally very good
mothers because well they're actually
very good partnerships as parents
whereas mammals and generally the
females the mothers make the father's
look dreadful because the fathers have
almost zero to do with raising their
youngsters for various complicated
reasons so who do I think is the best
mother which species other than me Oh
mum um why don't we go with the worst
mothers first who the mothers that are
the worst by our [ __ ] well I guess those
would be mothers that would allow their
youngsters to be devoured eaten or
killed because they knew that they would
just make another one again fairly
quickly and so perhaps mothers like
scrub hares perhaps
I don't know how much protection scrub
her mother's afford there leverets I
don't think very much at all and
obviously if we're looking at birds will
we doubt we know the two worst mothers
that we all worst parents at jhummer
knows the Egyptian geeses in its just
reminding me the Egyptian geese that
live at above us again but though
they're individuals not species and I
suppose then by the same criteria we
should say that the mothers that put the
most effort into their youngsters and
the most protective of them should be
those that get the crown of being the
best mothers and then I suppose it must
go to the social animals and so lions
and as Lauren said hyenas and elephants
I think of all of those the mother most
likely to do damage to some things
threatening her babies would be an
elephant mother and so I suppose by
human standards that would make them
very good mothers you know hyenas will
abandon a den if it's too threatened by
the Predators they'll leave their babies
inside and just disappear we know that
mother Lions will abandon their cubs in
extremis so I think we should vote for
elephants I think we should vote for and
so we shall elephants it is
of course all female animals are just as
good or mothers as they need to be in
order for their species to propagate
give or take I mean there are some
little bits of better than others in the
same way that some human beings are
better mother's than others and that's
often got to do with well it's got to do
with multitude of factors something of
its genetics some of its environmental
some of its cultural and some of its
most of it is an interaction of all
those three things and the same goes for
animals as well some will be just more
skillful than others
April insect Mother's not particularly
good I suppose if you think of a
something like a termite colony and now
she doesn't give any care at all in fact
her children start feeding hers almost
as soon as they're born if I'm thinking
of a termite colony or a or a beehive I
think of an insect that gives parental
care
well arachnids yes scorpions remember
many scorpions will carry their babies
around on their backs for quite some
time and so they're very good protective
mothers I think birds in general are
good especially those that have to build
nests or not have altricial youngsters
so youngsters that are our born
completely helpless doves for example
and dubs of course making a little bit
of milk for their youngsters I'm just
going to go and look quickly on our
boundary here because I heard a Franklin
charting but the number of Franklin's
that I've followed up on today have been
very disappointing
all right Jamie's left or elephant now
and I have no dark she'll be heading
fairly soon towards the hyena den I
think it's tricky to talk about
different or to compare different
mothering styles obviously there are
always do that I think I'm allergic to
being live mm-hmm I think that it goes
without saying that something like an
insect or a certain types of reptiles
don't really compare to with the
mothering skills of something like an
elephant a lion elephants and lions I
think are such a nice example because
they are so committed to raising not
just their own offspring but the
offspring of others and they really care
about the offspring within their herd or
they pride
I II knows but more selective in that
whole process they really only care
about the their own Cubs and the Cubs of
their female relatives so I think it is
I think it's difficult to really compare
I think it goes without saying that we
should talk about
Karuna in terms of her success rate and
she managed to raise five litters of
Cubs to adulthood or at least almost two
to independence certainly husana
survived and therefore I think it's safe
to to say that all of her you know she
that all five letters were successful
typically you know and we talk about
successful litters of Cubs we talk about
them reaching the age of independence
but since Hassanein did manage to stay
independent then I think it qualifies so
a gorilla definitely gets a mansion she
really defied the odds it's very very
unusual for a leopard to manage to
accomplish that lionesses when they
defend their cubs or forces to be
reckoned with I know I've seen as it's
terrifying
Birds the way that Birds look after
their youngsters
Christene yes baboons are a really good
example of being protective over their
offspring they are they are deeply
protective they do care enormous ly for
their own babies again very similar to
the hyena type situation is actually a
lot of parallels between baboons and
hyenas the females really are devoted to
their babies and their relatives and
their friends and they do have a social
hierarchy within the troop within the
group the same applies to monkeys but
they will defend their babies that's how
my cousin got bitten by a baboon or
monkey I can't remember which oh so
young trying to take pick up a baby that
she decided needed rescuing and got
bitten zebra zebra a really good example
I've seen both zebra mares and stallions
go out of go put their lives at risk to
save their offspring I've seen it with
Buffalo I've seen an old female Buffalo
you're actually talking about it today
with cursed when we went for a little
bumble after drive we found the Inca
women's hunting Buffalo and they caught
a buffalo calf and the mother was
chasing them round and round I've
actually got some slow-motion of that I
must find it was awesome
to witness shame it wasn't too awesome
for the calf who got eaten pretty much
alive but she did really try to save her
baby and I could only assume it was her
baby I think it's really hard to compare
the mothering skills when you're talking
about things like mammals reptiles it's
a bit different birds are amazing
birds are devoted parents Wolfgang says
that his mom is also a very good mom
that's lovely Wolfgang we all of course
are terribly biased in favor of our own
mothers
they say they say biologists theorized
that it's one of the reasons why birds
of prey in the birds of prey the female
are larger than the male look I mean
this is a theory and I'm not a hundred
percent sure I buy it but the idea is
that the maternal instinct is stronger
than the paternal instinct and that
nature and its way has made the female
birds bigger to protect their chicks
from the male birds the father's just in
case the the hunting instinct overrides
the paternal instinct I don't really buy
that to be honest I mean the fathers are
left with their chicks on their own so
often that it doesn't really make sense
to me but hey it's a theory it's in a
book it's in a textbook so enough people
thought it might be okay
so there you go that's my input for what
it's worth I'm going to pop on to
tortured quickie to see whether there's
any track so while I do that let's head
across to Lauren to hear her final
thoughts on the subject
I did indeed have this thought in the
first place
and it is now golden hour my favorite
time of day when the Sun starts to set
and everything has that golden light so
I'm very happy however I'm not happy and
maybe the animals are avoiding me and
I'm not sure why maybe they're a little
bit upset that I left to go to the Mara
but we are looking we are driving I
promise insane so has the eagle eyes
so I believe there was quite a
discussion on the best mothers and
according to James I'm Jaime they also
do agree with the elephant point now I
think when you sort of categorically
divide male and female elephants are
actually very very different of course
are different but I mean the females
were very young age will spend a long
time learning how to be a mother from
their own mother and the other females
and a hair including a matriarch whereas
males and they obviously get are well
like human males they get a huge influx
of hormones especially testosterone and
they spend a lot of time head-butting
bashing one another trying to show who
is bigger who is braver who is more
dominant that is a very key driving
force for a male elephant
whereas a female concentrates all her
efforts into learning how to be a mother
is quite big difference and that
generally is why the sort of teenage if
you like male elephants around 12 to 15
years do get kicked out normally by the
matriarch herself because they are just
too boisterous for the haird oh emma has
just informed me seventy seven percent
of the viewers of all of you agree with
the elephant yeah I think I think that's
the one my heart is set on an elephant
makes an absolutely fantastic mother
eyes for the wars mothers where James
Wayne I'm not even sure I could answer
that that is a fairy
tricky one the worst mother is there
such a thing possibly yes
but I'm glad everyone agrees I think I'm
gonna confirm my final answer as
elephants making absolutely fantastic
mothers out here in the animal kingdom
and where are they where are the
elephants and all the oh just when
interest by the web
do you control is asking about the
elephant diet which is very interesting
because okay it completely differs
between the two seasons that we have out
here and elephants obviously travel vast
distances they don't they're not
stationary or staying within a very
small territory or anything like that
they obviously travel very far for water
and for food so generally during the
summer time they tend to eat a lot more
of the grass it's obviously much richer
there's a lot more water around you to
the rains and they will feed
predominantly about 80% on the grass 20%
more on sort of the trees and shrubs and
the more drier elements of the
vegetation
however when winter does come it does a
complete flood so obviously they're dry
grass is no good for them so they will
mainly focus on trees and shrubbery
about 80% the other 20% will be any sort
of nutritious grasses that they do fine
oh we got a beautiful sunset I'm gonna
do a u-turn as I talk so and Amarra it's
also completely different the elephants
actually the diet doesn't do a you flip
like oh okay Saints always got a bit of
an idea so we're gonna go with it
it's very excited with these ideas so in
the Mara it is actually completely
different because the seasons are not
the same as Juma is that okay sense he's
gonna give you a perfect view of the
gorgeous sunset that we see so yes the
elephants in the Mara predominantly feed
on grasses all year runs completely
different diet due to environment now
look at that beautiful setting that we
have here Sands was being very fussy
he's making me where there's just a
little bit so that we can get the Sun
through the trees for you there we go
took a bit of practice what we did it
isn't that beautiful
sometimes obviously we don't have any
animals it's worth just stopping and
taking a look at the Sun seen it's not
perfectly in the middle steins is it are
you okay with that
yeah he's okay that's good so boom back
to the elephants because it was a really
really interesting question the diet
will differ depends on on seasonal
changes within the localized areas and
just environmental factors and of course
that then correlates to the fact that
how long an elephant lives because they
are said to live a lot longer in the
Mara elephants main cause of death other
than parasites or disease is actually
the wearing down of the molars they have
six sets of molars that come at
different stages throughout their life
and the last set the six set comes in at
normally on average around forty seven
years old and they were wear down from
the different food that they eat and of
course grassy is compared to trees and
shrubs is obviously very very different
grass as much softer and it won't wear
the teeth down as much whereas branches
trees and shrubbery will of course where
the teeth die much faster so that is why
the elephants in Namara are said to live
a little bit longer than the elephants
here in Juma and the Kruger because they
do eat trees need to eat shrubbery they
wear their teeth down faster and once
that last set of molars is completely
worn down the elephants are not able to
feed any longer and that is normally the
main cause of death with an older
elephants and that's why they are said
to live approximately around sixty years
of age so fascinating question but quite
a in-depth explanation as we stare this
absolutely gorgeous sunset Saints those
doing a great job there the golden glow
was cast all over Juma and this is
actually the hour that the well the
leopards for sure do tend to get up it's
it's such a tranquil time of day and
obviously it's been very hot today the
temperatures start to cool things start
to a week and so you never know we're
banking on the fact that we're gonna
walk in will drive into a walking
leopard please do send all your leopard
vibes to us it's been sold
I've seen any of them this unjust you're
starting to lose that full circle no it
started in schools I'm very very fast
soon we will be in darkness it's just
incredible
definitely worth JUnit you turn four
amazing and this is the time of day when
things really start to change and I can
personally feel it even when I'm
underwater so I'm gonna relate to both
realms on land and underwater this sort
of sunset hour is really when your
daytime animals are seen right okay this
is it nighttime is coming darkness is
coming
predators are coming out it really is
time for them to sort of get together
and huddle together or find their hiding
spot or go into their burrow depending
on which animal you're talking about
and of course and the coral reefs is the
exact same it's no different you will
have your daytime fish that are thinking
for example your parrotfish parrotfish
or key species within your coral reef
ecosystem and their diurnal so once it
does get to that sunset hour you can see
their behavior completely change and it
is time for them to go in to hide them
so they'll find a little rock or a
crevice or any sort of protruding part
of a substrate where they can hide and
what they do is they produce a mucus
bubble from their lips so it's almost
like this is gonna sound not very nice
but well okay you know when you blow a
bubble with chewing gum or bubble gum I
think I definitely used to do that when
I was a kid I don't anymore it's like
doing that but they do it with their own
saliva and it's quite a large bubble and
it completely envelopes the whole body
so there it's like a little cocoon of
saliva which doesn't sound great and it
completely protects them from odours
being released so the Predators cannot
actually smell the parrotfish so it's
the same in the coral reefs as it is on
one the diurnal animals will begin to
change change your behavior it's time to
go into hiding and of course the
nighttime animals come on that is what I
am banking on right now so as sensor
when I just watch the last glimpse of
the Sun going down we're gonna send you
across the genes and see what he's up to
I'm looking for any animals really but
we've had some exciting news we've just
been told by one of the guides from our
atossa
that they found tracks of a male and a
female leopard coming in to Juma round
where the old hyena den is on the shoe
bomber road which is sort of middle
centre or central south and we've just
come there we have confirmed their
tracks are coming on to Juma they're
going in towards treehouse Dam
so that's where we hid it so that's very
exciting if we get very lucky we might
have a possibly Hawk amore and a sea
buoy mating if we don't get lucky we'll
have nothing so I'm going to drive with
relative speed see if we can't get lucky
see boy he is a female leopard that
occurs to the south of us in this
general vicinity she's sort of well I
guess she's sort of West I know she's
off she do lose territory and yeah I
guess waste of good Chavez I thought she
was a little further south net let's
just stop here and show you quite
magnificent picture and see if we can't
hear some alarming all the tell-tale
sound of mating lipids isn't that
wonderful beautiful kudos on a termite
mound they do this just for Vantage and
if they could see the lipids they would
be going ah
two youngsters
I'm sure the rest of the herd is around
here somewhere they're just enjoying a
little Sunday evening peep out from the
top of the termite man
something moving in the grass next or
some pretty sure it's a Franklin and not
a livid
yes that's a factor that can see it
all righty we're going to carry on
didn't hear any leopard mating his hands
do make a tremendous noise when they're
made to do lipids and so it's quite a
nice way of finding them Deborah you say
that was beautiful it is just wonderful
they are such elegant and T Lupe's
there's a big bull antelope and there's
two mummies we're gonna carry on not
because we don't appreciate them but
because the light is fading fast and TV
is coming
I think what we'll probably do thank you
very much that all of you are sending me
luck we will need it entirely sure this
was the wisest route to take like maybe
you should just gone straight to the dam
and stopped and listened there anyway we
will be there soon enough you difficult
to track them become darkness
all right here we'll turn north over
here Oh Rajee
well I'm hurry-up them drive about and
do my best to find these Katz's go back
to Lauren who's given up on her sons it
we have moved on from the sunset and we
did have a beautiful crested bar but
just posing fantastically so in front of
the car
but obviously hair dye must always say
live live live live more like that and
of course flew off which is a shame
because it was an absolute beautiful
view of a beautiful bird oh well very
typical in the world of birds I swear
they know they just know exactly when
we're gonna go live and they fly off and
that is the life of a bird so continuing
on my bum is gone rather numb here so
it's gonna shuffle around and do hope
that the animals come to me Sansa said
he would bring all his luck with them
he's even got lucky socks on today he's
always got socks on since I was a sock
man
Oh Irene's asking a good question it
stopped me in my tracks iya stop me from
going on a roundabout sans or socks what
do I think are better mothers aquatic
animals or land animals very interesting
question could probably have a great
discussion about that but I think
generally it's very general very broad
without going into specific examples I
do think it has to be land animals
mammals of course is a broad category
and they generally generally generally
tend to sort of show the highest level
of maternal care and there's even a few
examples of paternal care in there as
well so I do think one's animals
definitely sure the higher level of
maternal and paternal care
however our aquatic animals is a huge
diversity huge huge spectrum that we
could actually talk about and each
individual animal will do what it can
for its young the mean sort of driving
factor and the animal kingdom is
reproduction is to reproduce it's to you
know keep going with your bloodline and
spread your genetics far and wide that
is sort of the main goal within many
know all animals really so within the
aquatic realm that's exactly what the
animals do and they will do what they
have to sure to ensure their young have
a great and successful start to life but
that might not necessarily involve
direct maternal care so might not
necessarily involve suckling and keeping
the young in dens and things like that
but they will do absolutely everything
and explain how much energy that they
can actually afford to expend looking
after their young to ensure they get the
best start in life even if it is just
dispersal so some people forget that
coral is actually an animal it doesn't
look like an animal
doesn't behave it's what we classify as
an animal but it is it's in the sort of
grouping Nigeria the same as jellyfish
there's a very basic level of animal but
it's still an animal
and the what we see when we look at
these hard structures is actually the
exoskeleton inside there is an animal
and how they reproduce is by spawning so
at a certain time of the year within a
particular moon phase these animals will
just spawn they'll just release all the
gametes into the ocean and just hope for
the best and that is an animal that's
doing that and obviously there's very
very very little material or paternal
care that goes into that but there's a
lot of energy expended and that is what
they strive to do release surgeries
which will of course meet in the ocean
together and then they will settle they
need a hard substrate to settle on and
then that is how the start of coral
grows it's a very beginning of coral
life and it's fascinating and maybe
doesn't sound very relevant out here but
it's still an animal
so Irena I think it was fantastic
question and you Vito I could go on and
on and on about that saying that's
giving me very funny looks from the back
here but yes there's such a broad
spectrum of parental care and land
animals I think definitely wouldn't add
that but your a great question what a
topic even though I haven't finds much
today
we definitely have had some fantastic
discussions that's for sure
and I'm still hoping that something is
just going to walk into my path because
I'm clearly not doing very well at fun
dance however I'm not giving up hope
just yet obviously we have our TV show
tonight as you all know and the animals
do love to be on TV that's one thing I
will say left or right left or right
what do you think sense 5050 we're just
looking we haven't found any tracks to
follow as of yet
so I'm Julia whole life sans always says
left I don't know why when I see left or
I said left black like black no matter
where it takes you okay so we're heading
north we really have covered the
southern boundary quite extensively this
morning so this morning this afternoon
I apologized so we're hoping for our
best by traveling slightly north like I
said please do send all your good vibes
and it's Sunday the animals do know that
it is cheap each tour and it's time to
pop out and make an appearance they all
love their moments on television
otherwise we will continue to drive
no but it's starting to get a little bit
chilly this one is say to him within the
next few minutes I may have to pull over
and put my jersey on I actually call it
jumper but a lot of people out here make
fun of me when I say jumper so I don't
know if it's a British word or just the
strange Lauryn Ward but I call them
jumpers but everybody laughs so I'm just
gonna switch to Jersey just don't be
made funnel there's a lot of things that
I get made fun for I made fun of in camp
but jumper is definitely one of them
Emma said she likes jumper so yes thanks
I'm always giving me support and not yet
I like jumper dudes it's the word that
I've been brought up with I'm not sure
exactly what is funny about it
but obviously it's entertaining to some
other people so talking of that you're
gonna have to bear with me while I
actually put it on wherever it is it was
probably not even a jumper is probably a
fleece but there we go thank you for
your patience everyone sans was all
wrapped up in the back he always is I
hate to think how you would survive in
Scotland sensor aim was enticing she
imagines animals like Impala peed in
their jerseys on yes I mean of course
animals that adapt to environmental
conditions including temperature and
seasonal changes I mean it's what they
are they're you know it's what they're
used to they wrote just a dad but I do
often wonder it can't be easy being an
animal out here and in certain
conditions and of course they are
prepared for it but oh when the way
there gets really cold here I can't
imagine is much fun being out here when
the wind is blowing and the open clear
and erring areas definitely wouldn't be
me
I'd much rather be tucked into bed okay
back to game on point animals where are
you
I wonder why they're all hiding from us
I had a good feeling about today has
been a very very quiet few days since I
have been back oh hey mousey there's no
a discussion about jumper or Jersey or
jacket this actually isn't technically
what I would call a jumbo jumpers what
you pull pool on like yeah that's that
sense so sweater I think that's a the
American term
I wonder what jumper does come from if
anyone does know please do let us know
all righty it looks like I've heard some
good news in my ear so we are gonna send
you across to miss Patterson just find
something very exciting surprise I
managed to actually do something I found
an animal I found an animal from scratch
almost okay I actually found an animal
by smelling and then I saw a hyena
eating a bit of something then Craig
spotted a dead impala underneath the
weeping waffle and then the hyenas
chased the leopard away and here we are
and then she's not who I was expecting
at all but here we have it I thought
there was a female leopard hanging
around somewhere on this eastern Western
sorry side of Torchwood apologize
there's no way I'll be able to be live
and moving with where we are of some
signal that's why you didn't see any of
the action between the lip and the
hyenas
let me see if I can call Rickson
you should see me no I can't use my
radio it's not working
they've just driven past me and there's
nothing I can do my radio won't work my
signal word work up they've found me if
not this is really quite infuriating why
I won't fight you and just to confirm
they found us here we go this certainly
doesn't look like Columba and it
certainly doesn't look like tündi it
does almost look like kochava what Craig
first guess unless
Columba has somehow grown up immensely
in the time since I last saw her I'm
pretty certain that that's well I think
that's who we've got barely seen her
properly the only time I saw her face
was when she was looking longingly oh
here come the hyenas hey troubles no
don't you chase my leopard away or at
least don't you chase my leopard further
on to Torchwood if you don't mind
oh geez
it's fascinating to watch the dynamics
between a leopard and a and a hyena two
very different animals and the hyena of
course will always be I'm just gonna
lighter a briefly 4x and so she you can
see where she is a hyena will always
always chase away a leopard from a kilt
a female leopard at least but at the
same time just watch she's the kochava
it's most definitely good Java
oh don't go that way
she's gonna go further down towards
Torchwood down for a drink which is
going to make our lives very difficult I
may not be seeing you much while I try
and follow her because I'm just gonna
try and stick with her in the vain hope
that she moves further towards a signal
area okay while we figure this out I'm
gonna send you across to James to see
what he has planned in his hour of need
I am indeed we have had no further sound
or sight or tracks or anything of the
supposed mating pair of leopards let's
just stop and have a quick listen here
very nice that Jamie's had some success
on Torchwood let's just hope that the
signal holds so we went to tree house
down we sat there for a while didn't
hear anything that's oh no we're gonna
sit here and see if I can hear anything
the tracks didn't seem to go up the road
which means means I think they came into
the block over here somewhere
some babbles shouting that's about all
let's go and just quickly check this old
hyena dude we've got nothing to lose by
doing that it's just over here
and it's all of you saying nighttime
sounds it's a lovely in winter there are
nice I don't think they're as nice as
they are in summer but they're certainly
nice very quiet just the old sound and
obviously any sound like a hyena sound
or a leopard sound will travel that much
further without all the leaves on the
trees and with the air being that much
less filled with moisture not sure how
that works physically does the old high
in the den nobody home
oh I'm on a second some lions and Gauri
main road hang on a second
I'm going to get hold of Lauren Lauren
do you copy Lauren
Lauren do you want to try and get into
that society on guy main road
okay so Lauren's right there yeah I
think see if you can get in tries
probably being run on the Eastern
Channel I am now seeing the old lipid
track going up the road here anyway
let's keep trying here and maybe we'll
go and try the hi Nadine but those lions
sound like they're in a good position
for us just to offer chitwa good okay
hopefully things are coming together
it's a big Torchwood pride I'm listening
on the radio
who knows
I'm going to do another stop and listen
just up here I think that they've
probably gone into a block and have been
sleeping most of the day and hopefully
the mating will start again
let's just hope Lauren can get into that
sighting it's gonna be tricky of course
because it's northern and eastern
Channel
which means that everyone from Chitra
and everyone from the North Wars had be
trying to get in but by now they will be
thinking about going and having this
sundowner sir
maybe we'll be lucky lads of course we
ought to get up and go to Torchwood
immediately
David isn't hearing growling from lipids
that are in love with each other
beautiful sound of the white plant scrub
Robin
well I have one more road to check and
then we're going to have to move on
lights on
hello I love snacks if you just joined
us well done I love snacks - believe it
or not oh this is distressing I'm pretty
sure that the technical department is
supposed to have a look at that today
right okay well there we go we've made a
solution um I love snacks we think it's
probably hook amore and Cebu Eve but it
could be quite wrong but I think that's
what's going on here no not working so
well there we go
it seems to be okay
Psalms dawat Brad scrub Robin
now you're just gonna stay with me at
the moment because Lauren is going to
struggle to get into that siting so
she'll try Oh
Tony Eagle flying blind didn't see it
sorry about that and Jamie is trying to
sort out what's going on with kochava
and whether or not she can actually
remain there on the count of the fact of
the signal is Sara Bominable these are
the pressures of television everybody
just listening to the radio I'm not
hearing Lauren try and call herself in
she may just arrive and better eyelids
it then that would be that'll suffice
yeah well learn sometime
so it is Mother's Day now I'm not making
conversation you can see because I've
nothing biological to tell you and there
was something I wanted to tell you about
Mother's Day oh yes I remember telling
you this before and I remember many of
you being utterly scandalized by and
that is of course that my family doesn't
do Mother's Day for some reason we don't
do mother's or Father's Day and my
mother today despite the fact that she
birthed me some 42 years in the distant
past has now taken it upon herself to be
hurt that we are not doing Mother's Day
42 years it's taken her I suppose it's
quite a long time and so I guess from
now on I'm going to have to pay
attention to Mother's Day
oh I believe we're having it grim line
issues I'm sorry about that let's go to
a clip
try the highness
hello everybody sorry about that we have
sorted out our problems whatever they
were they are beyond my Ken or
understanding I haven't come up with any
mating lipids just yet I'm afraid so
what we're going to do is go to the
hyena den see if Lauren can get into
that lion sighting enviar trying to get
in there but once she does get in it'll
be well worth while
anyway that's going to be our plan
I hope I didn't shock anyone my telling
you all that we didn't don't do Mother's
Day we do now of course in my family do
Mother's Day we'll be doing it from this
day onward I suspect it was because my
nephews have you know been told to draw
Mother's Day cards at school and so
they've given their mother my
sister-in-law Mother's Day cards and my
mother suddenly thought well hang on a
second
what about me fair enough mum
we are getting a new spotlight brought
to us because this one does not function
any longer
and I'm going to run it to other woman
car I would write cuckoos as extremely
clever mothers if not particularly
loving remember the cuckoo mother never
ever actually meets its offspring which
i think is quite astonishing so the only
kind of the only kind of parental care
that a cuckoo gives is to produce an
eggy and that's it never sees its baby
so it's very clever but it's not
particularly laughing you know I don't
think that they are the kinds of mothers
that receive Mother's Day carts on
Mother's Day my mother's not like a
cuckoo she's a very sweet woman she has
been very good to me all my years now we
are going to try and get into the hyena
den I believe that the hyena den that is
active is the one that Jerry and I found
the other day and Andre genre called
Jerry's den because Jerry happened to be
on the car and he nutrit irritate me
as it's what was that oh that's a pity
we have another technical problem that's
my fault we lost a piece of the yes we
lost a screwdriver spanner a tray a
battery Pearlstein maybe this is karma
maybe as we sit here the lipids will
cool no no the universe is giving us
nothing the moment
alrighty we have looked no other fees
it's only me I'm afraid this is awesome
35 minutes to kickoff it's going to be
the S AVC show of 1 and what's going to
happen is of course is that the hyenas
are going to be absent from their den
it's just up here
[Music]
ken I'm sorry I missed that one we'll
get it again
ken oh it was an update
thank you Ken for your update whatever
it was a child of the universe you want
to know Jerry as Jerry as a producer for
wild earth and food areas she was here
last week and so she came on Drive with
Jean Dre and I one day that happens from
time to time we allow the ladies out of
the office
not sure how wise that is but we do
allow that to happen
where is the best to route get into this
place probably a little bit further
along let's keep going
maybe we'll bump into the lipids
then they yes I've been thinking
positive all day now I can tell you for
free that I let me let me tell you a bit
about positive thinking and visualizing
I remember being told visi at a young
age that you need to visualize your
goals and some fellow came to the school
to teach us about visualizing your goals
and how winners visualize and see
themselves with great success and that's
how you do it that was the secret of
success so I took this to heart aged 12
or 13 and I visualized myself in the
blue jersey of the sanjana's college
first 15 playing with the number 9 on my
back that is the scrum-half
and I visualized myself more than I
visualized myself doing anything else
scoring tries making tackles kicking
goals and basically being the best rugby
player in the world and I promise you I
visualized that more than any other
rugby player has ever visualized
themselves and I played when I finally
got to the end of my school career my
visualisation techniques got saw me
playing not for the first 15 in fact but
for the fourth 15 so that didn't work so
well then also I used to visualize very
frequently being in parlor
I used to visualize very frequently
being caught in or having a tryst in a
darkened corner somewhere with a teenage
fancy of the time you know maybe in the
tech room at the stables or in a bush of
the schools social that sort of thing I
used to visualize that also almost as
much as I visualized the rugby and I can
safely say to you that not one of the
girls I ever visualized having a brief
tryst with ever looked sideways at me
but to sort of spit in my general
direction so I do not have big believer
in positive thinking and visualizing but
I know it works for lots of other people
oh this is wonderful
Lorentz visualization or my work on the
radio has managed to knit her a lion
well I want to thank you all for your
fantastic vibes that you did send my way
because we have what we call very
correctly and very scientifically a
last-minute lion right on the middle of
the road on the southern boundary we
have a line there is actually another
lioness there as well but we obviously
don't have a great view of her so all I
can see of course night has fallen and
we are using IR the infrared light we
see two lioness so just to let you know
the sort of artificial light that you
can be that you can see being shown on
the lioness at the moment is more common
from us there are other vehicles around
we are obviously using our I our nicest
lioness is obviously having the perfect
cat map in the middle of the road even
if you wanted to drive across this road
to get from A to B you literally
couldn't it's a huge roadblock and of
course the road must be lovely and warm
and cozy for this lioness now I have no
idea who she is we've just arrived and I
have the exact same view that you all
have so I don't know exactly who these
lion eyes are but of course we're gonna
stay with them and it is in perfect
timing for our show tonight so my luck
came in after two hours of driving
around and talking about jumpers and
Jerry's and Switzer cos we find an
animal so I am very happy about this I'm
just very intrigued to known from this
beautiful female eyes she's huge she's a
large female block in the wall of the
middle of the road and clearly very
sleepy I just wonder who she is think
almost haven't been seen in that time
obviously there was a terrible news
about Nana which was very upsetting for
all of us but these scenes from what I
can gather
to not be in June so who these lioness
are they could be then go hormones but
one day I'm gonna check on that before I
give you a confirmation - apology there
we go signs you are a star you can just
get a few of the other lion eyes right
on the life there mrs. Anna scene one or
two we can only see two so at the minute
we have one sleeping right on the road
and just another one sort of lying on
the grass just to the left there which
you can see that someone is shining a
light on now I'm not sure if there's any
further up ahead there's a large
possibility that there actually could be
unfortunately the nighttime makes it a
little bit trickier to tell that but
from what we can see the minute there
are two lioness both resting both doing
pretty much about lion Street which is a
whole lot of nothing
but I am that we actually find some cats
so I just really want to know exactly
who they are I give my voice a little
bit lower because sir
obviously our other vehicles around us
also looking at the lines and they can
see some lights coming in so there's
more approaching but I'm very intrigued
I thought it was gonna be a leopard that
I found today but huh its lions
see my again I apologize about that like
I'm really not
oh girl there you go the perfect lion
pose there should actually be opposing
yoga's something after lions the way
they lie sprawled out like this so I am
in the biggest fan of using artificial
lights on animals at nighttime although
they are nocturnal animals it's really
really not best advice that you use
lights like this even underwater it's
not just on ones artificial lights is
really not good to shine on the animal
so what I think we're gonna do here
because we're not in the best position
on one vehicle has actually left is
we're just gonna turn around go to the
other side and try and get a better view
of the lion species and figure out who
they are so bear with me oh she's just
giving us a beautiful view of her face
can we just have a look at that sense
hey girl aren't you stung and sleepy
clearly you know that way when you're so
tired that your eyes start to rule in
your head and you just can't control
that I think that's what this lovely
lioness is feeling right now okay so
bear with us you just want to be
possession
go the other vehicles moving so I just
see where there's other vehicle goals my
name we are gonna pull up a little bit
closer there we go perfect
I love it when the other vehicles me by
the way alrighty just bear with
okay I stole a car that's fantastic
Lauren always stole sayings how is that
for you things get stolen in a perfect
position there we go so now we can get a
clearer much clearer view of the two
lioness where is the rest of your praise
girls are sleepy sleepy grows now of
course
lions are primarily nocturnal or they
can be active during the day so
depending on exactly how actively have
been journaling depends on how much cat
napping they will need to do for the
night and what I can guess here right
now is these lines have been very active
through the day which is why they are
catching there are few snooze ease on
the road here right now so what ygritte
fine for the last minute lions thank you
everybody for joining us today we do
apologize about the lack of luck but it
all came in in the end so please do join
us tomorrow for your sunrise safari see
you then
[Music]